sorry I can't rant today I can only be
awakened by a Disney film with a
completely original premise yep still
waiting oh hey I tell you what I can
also be awakened by a kiss from Angelina
Jolie okay and that's never gonna happen
luckily I've been awakened by the fiery
kiss of my own rage Disney made its name
by pilfering storylines from fairy tales
but these days Disney is going further
now the company cannibalizes its own
repellants live-action updates an Alice
in Wonderland and The Sorcerer's
Apprentice endless movies based on the
Pirates of the Caribbean ride infinite
installments of a straight to DVD series
about Tinker Bell and even wait wait
wait wait not yet I'm building to
something here luckily Disney has also
stolen several pages from the book
wicked which turned the Wicked Witch of
the West into a complicated heroine this
approach actually feels fresh and it's
pulling in big box office for the House
of mouse Disney did its own back story
of the Wicked Witch in Oz a great and
powerful
frozen reimagines the evil Snow Queen as
an empowered ice diva and now there's
going to be a whole movie centered on
Maleficent the body from the 1959 film
Sleeping Beauty well
I want to hate Maleficent they've
apparently turned one of the most
memorable villains of cinema into some
sort of Lorax who speaks for the trees
but I can't I just can't and it's not
because she wharfs into a fearsome
dragon it's not even because she has the
most badass hat and villain done better
even than odd-jobs razor bring bowler
it's simply that she deserves to be a
protagonist Disney is trying valiantly
to reimagine princesses as spunky action
heroes but the Evil Queen's of the
wicked witches are the only strong
female characters in the classic flicks
I mean sure Maleficent bends the rules a
little to achieve her goals but is she
really a worse role model than that
passively about Sleeping Beauty Disney's
also prepping a movie about Cruella de
Vil from 101 Dalmatians smart move we
could read igger the entire Disney mo
and do nothing but villains I want to
give out scar from The Lion King or the
Underminer from Incredibles in fact the
greatest fictional villain on the mall
is in the public domain
Disney look no further than Lucifer from
Paradise Lost just think of the
potential musical numbers Disney have
your people call my people I'll send
over a treatment
who's your favorite Disney villain
Ursula for Little Mermaid the hunter
from Bambi let me know in the comments
and subscribe to the wire channel